breaking tonight federal prosecutors say
a Coast Guard officer who has been
arrested on gun charges had a hit list
and intended to target civilians
lieutenant Christopher Paul Hansen was
taken into custody by FBI agents in
Maryland prosecutors say they found
evidence Hansen was focusing on
prominent politicians and TV
personalities national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin is live
tonight with details on this could even
Jennifer good evening Brett the details
in this affidavit are chilling federal
prosecutors say they arrested an active
duty Coast Guard lieutenant Christopher
Paul Hassan who allegedly planned to
kill top Democratic lawmakers and media
personalities he described himself as a
white nationalist who wanted to
establish a white homeland and said I am
dreaming of a way to kill almost every
last person on earth
the affidavit provides shocking details
quote the defendant intends to murder
innocent civilians on a scale rarely
seen in this country he must be detained
pending trial the FBI raided his cramped
Silver Spring Maryland apartment where
they found a cache of guns and evidence
that he was targeting prominent
politicians and TV personalities from
MSNBC and CNN who he called traitors he
had worked at Coast Guard headquarters
since 2016 and conducted searches on his
work computer he was arrested on federal
weapons and drug charges last week
lieutenant Hassan had a spreadsheet of
targets those individuals included Joey
who most likely is Joe Scarborough of
MSNBC based on his computer searches
Chris Hayes from MSNBC Senator Richard
Blumenthal House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
Senators Tim Kaine Chuck Schumer Kirsten
Gillibrand Elizabeth Warren
congresswoman Alexandria Kashia Cortes
senator Cory Booker among others
prosecutors say this Coast Guard
lieutenant who they described as a
domestic terrorist wrote about
biological attacks and had a hit list
court papers suggest lieutenant
Christopher Paul Hassan held these views
for years citing a June 2017 email
outlining an attack with a biological
weapon the FBI found 15 firearms and
more than one thousand rounds of
ammunition in his apartment he is slated
to appear in a
Maryland Court on Thursday prosecutors
are saying these charges are the quote
proverbial tip of the iceberg
Brett will follow this Jennifer thank
you